[Music]
three two one action
hey guys welcome back to off the record
we talk about whatever we want we got to
hear back man give me two that was these
guys think of me you think I'm just
getting down with the lumber I thought
that you were into more saving and more
doing stop how much is it a share yeah
it's awesome it's good it's going up
cool they don't have enough employees I
feel like every time I got a Home Depot
I'm playing hide and seek with the
[ __ ] employee copies are the keys of
me I'm just standing here
yeah but yeah I don't think you guys
have ever been to Fry's Electronics did
[ __ ] that's it those cities three
employees a frontal it it's a [ __ ]
airport in there and also there's one
employees you never know where they are
going to home people on your like I have
too many employees he sees you he's like
oh depot
what pisses me about Home Depot is like
it's so [ __ ] big and they never know
where anything is it's like everybody is
on their first day but they have a
[ __ ] thing right here where they
could search it yeah
but hey you [ __ ] around coming across
the kid that's not a strong speller like
I thought this kid I was looking for the
can aerosol like the air it became and I
was like hey bro what's the the canned
air he's like well I was like the
aerosol like the cannons they could put
air in a can like that right he
literally typed in a IR oh it's it took
somebody else why another cousin was
like it's a ero
and like the look and he told you what I
all that was a disappointment in my face
I was like not only want to sit Oh Air
Assault it D makes this [ __ ] kiddin
Alyssa what Brandi have you guys been a
losed oh yeah it's like the nice version
of Home Depot really yeah ever been
inside it depends on where you are
though I really noticed yeah cuz I'm in
the Van Nuys area and everything's kind
of wrecked because every lo that [ __ ]
just even the lights are a little bit
brighter it really looks nice like it
feels like you're going into like a yeah
I'm a creature of habit I thought of a
Home Depot so I can't like switch yeah I
can't like it just it just feels weird
to me to just go to Lowe's I feel like
I'm cheating on Home Depot your hood
hoppin yeah
no chair hopping like you go to a barber
you go to another barber seat in the
same barbers only if that barber grants
you permission like oh I'm gonna be goin
that tweet such a such a take care of if
you just come and be like oh he's not
here
cut me real quick written law when I
first moved out here I was finding
barbershops and I was his one is wonder
who cut me and I did not like I was cut
so the next week I went back and I got
another guy didn't even speak to the guy
that [ __ ] my hair up like hi I'm
taking about last night
I'll and it did the podcast and I had a
short I don't have time I didn't take my
trim on the road with me so my hair
started growing and if I don't trim it
like I would get ingrown hair and I like
my mic's gets irritated really fast so I
said miss Barbara see random barbershop
I go in the guy I tell him exactly what
I'm on don't push my beard down just
clean me up right here and then clean it
up right here with your the whole thing
with the hot towel and then I'll do all
that only at all that just just trimmer
with the t liner and then trim around it
with the T line but then take the
straight razor and just make it Chris
talk him exactly what I want he just
used the t liners right right I think he
didn't clean it all up and I hear you
didn't clean it here and then he gives
me the mirror like he's done
what did you say you can tell you can
see listen some and they're right here
like I don't know like it like drops
like almost like a stare and I'm just
like yeah he's like hey yeah all right
man $7 I'm like you're not done pick the
[ __ ] Clippers Becca go back to work
like but I feel like he was all messing
up more cause he already pushed he
doesn't know what he's doing he
obviously he's trying to talk to me he's
like I was like yeah I gotta show you
come around like yeah he's like yeah I'm
a comedian too I was like no I was like
yeah I haven't done anything like for
years I was like then you're not a
comedian no you were he's a barber right
and you're not a good mom no he's more
like this world looks that's what my
jokes are really bad I was so mad last
night I had to just let it go it's like
$7 so I know what you're talking about
you see the lines peanut balls charming
looks good to me I'm very particular
about my appearance Goliath
I had to clean it up a little bit last
night I did it when I got home but yeah
he just yeah it's very easy did he just
hit it with clippers and not with a
razor did not hit the Rays it cuz I only
wanted right here I don't arrays in
under my neck and I don't do the razor
on my back so I was like I'm just not
gonna I didn't want him to touch my
lining because I didn't trust him sure
every time you want to shave you pay a
cat to shave you know I just didn't have
my clippers if I don't have my trimmer
somebody did it over the weekend yeah it
was just because I was gonna be onstage
in front of people or another I always
try to make sure I look decent the
people are paying money for it that's
very thoughtful
I mean money gotta be considerate I
never thought of it that way because I
always think about what's the most
comfortable way for me to be onstage I
get that and that matters too so you get
good genes but if I'm in front of people
and all eyes on me
I don't want like a blemish or something
to take away from the attention of my
joke people focusing in like oh he
didn't even save now you're so far no
let me I'm for to the people in the back
but the people in the front they say
everything see my nose and all of this
yeah yeah yeah I have to look the part
about it like you when I started
dressing how I want to be approached
like a lot of things changed like I
don't just run to the grocery store in
like joggers or sweats like that like I
put on a three-piece suit to go to Ralph
okay you have like sync funnier when
you're uglier uh if you're going for
that comp that type of comedy I want to
be like a cool funny guy I don't know
I gotta see that's funny I'm pretty
[ __ ] hilarious I mean I don't want a
tomorrow
I gotta see your style yeah cuz it the
brand depends on what your coming out
here I got like a Martin Lawrence I'm
cool and I do comedy rather than like
I'm a bottom Bobby Lee I'm a deep throat
this mic yeah Bobby Lee kissed a dick
yesterday on Instagram that [ __ ]
he got mad that I lost weight he's like
you're not gonna be as funny anymore but
that's his style as his file yeah you
know getting a fat baby but you know
what it's crazy because there's a comic
you can't be too attractive
like there are only a few comics that
pull off the pretty boy swag like they
like to see people that look like the
typical comic relief like fat guys or
tall guys it's not like that but if
you're too attractive especially with
ladies like they're on a lot of super
attractive comedians because it'll take
away from the jokes got to be focusing
in like she looks like a good leg could
never be funny I know I know it was suck
you got to put a bag of your face I've
got to be a lady he gave it to me [ __ ]
you see you can be really good to me you
can be like that poor Mouse call me who
knows if they're even under there they
probably got some other minions I know
they're just chilling at home collecting
cash so smart does David Hasselhoff
count as a comedian I think he's a
comedic actor he's not a comedian cuz he
doesn't have a cent a comedian has like
15 say yeah that's good oh she's reading
my mind if I'm saying he does he does a
whole album now and it's like okay this
is in the comedian zone is he trying to
be funny I don't think so he's crazy
right really he's like the new Andy
Kaufman dude maybe centric maybe maybe
it's a compact the waiver is so fast
Mobe it's it's like when Kaufman came
out a lot of people like is it a bit is
it a thing is he doing is you really
wrestling like it's like that kind of
[ __ ] but now we all know it was a bit
dessert list with the leather jacket he
doesn't let you yeah either [ __ ] has
wind holes on them and [ __ ] like a green
screen behind Michael feels himself cuz
I'm thinking like this [ __ ] in Germany
or something yeah oh he is [ __ ]
internationally because the Baywatch
duties the plan David Hasselhoff was the
most heartthrob is bad body built as guy
that I had seen in the night that's what
I'm saying he's a beautiful man cuz to
me as a kid going I was like can we get
this guy off the screen and gold focus
on digging really this is before like
the grooming and manscaping and all that
[ __ ] like that hair got a little
triangle hair a heartthrob
that's a beautiful man uh-huh who is now
killing it in comedy who was them who
was the most beautiful man right now in
to you in any in any field in any
fielding act my comedy the most
beautiful most beautiful man all of your
Hemsworth the only one that matters
who's bad Chris Hemsworth Thor Oh
everyone the universal love story
he's a even ejective guy Matt Jason
Momoa or Momoa Jason whoa yeah he smells
I mean he's attractive but I don't know
is really hot but I wouldn't say he's
like the most beautiful
well he's not beautiful he's like a man
who did you say the most beautiful man
I've always a Chris he's beautiful
I can't look Ryan Gosling in his eyes if
I met him I would have the signal 8mr
no what did he be looking at dick shoes
man it's like cuz I feel like he looks
in your eyes he's gonna do this it's not
I'm like
come on let's get famous they actually
hired him because they said that he
wasn't like stereotypically attractive
really Gosling yeah for the notebook
that's the reason why they had what that
[ __ ] casting director that was but you
know like when I watch all these movies
what I like to do is I like to just
chill and order food like from post
mates and it don't even matter could be
like 4 p.m. it could be like 10 p.m. I
just need some ice cream I just need to
get some like fast food it's pretty cool
so this off the record is brought to you
by post mates yeah yeah post mates is
your personal food delivery grocery
delivery and whatever kind of delivery
year round your sign batteries even back
when we had a shoot and we ran out of
batteries and we didn't want to waste
the time to go all the way downstairs to
get the batteries and we got a post
middle all the way down already at that
in there but ya know what does someone
we're living in LA so it's like 25
floors down well that's better they
didn't have an elevator do penny also
have to walk like four miles to the
Ralph's because it's a penny ask you to
Cara okay basically anything you know
craving a point that's the point here
anything you're craving even batteries
you feel deliver it for you
right so yeah and it's 24 hours a day
365 days a year
post meets will bring you whatever you
need within the hour yes they're the
largest on-demand network in the US and
offer delivery from all these
restaurants grocery stores convenience
stores and traditional retailers you
could possibly want or need and what's
cool is there's no more trips to the
store you don't even need to know where
the store is
post mates will deliver anything to you
and you could down the app for iOS or
Android for free and browse local
restaurants and businesses and track
your delivery in real time so for a
limited time post mates is giving our
listeners $100 of free delivery credit
I'm just gonna do this myself yeah me
too first seven days that's a hundred
bucks yes okay so use the code off the
record and click the link in the
description box below
go ahead and download the app that's the
code off the record for $100 a free
delivery credit for your first seven
days and when you download the post
meets happy so anything you need anytime
you need it post made it down low post
mates and save the code with off the
record jaws the post mates for
sponsoring this off director yep
geo do you even know where the store is
I know where all the stores are you
should ask Bart this question because it
was parts idea don't cut me in why can't
I come you and your Lily married to the
cat no but you know how he is dude wait
what far worse the store you know with
the famous story I'll tell you where
okay there's a grocery store buy you yep
I've been in there yeah we're okay good
good job Vaughn zero sir okay I'm
thinking of this year Bo's when you walk
through the door where is the frozen
food section on the left yeah it's on
the right no I pizza both don't even
know where the frozen right there's like
this right here you could have just said
I don't need a lot of frozen food no cuz
I know where it is
I'm gonna lie it's on the right no it's
right there but please don't clump us in
together please we don't make the same
life choices okay okay we'll see why is
the shopping in the family I do what see
you go to the store together I don't I I
rouse order everything bro I see them a
few more absolutely absolutely I'm not
bring I'm not bringing up the car why
cuz I'm lazy okay I have money now so
I'm not doing you do Amazon fresh I
don't I just do wraps wraps delivers
within two hours I didn't know what and
you still get the feel to it is it what
a dump
how much extra do they charge like to
knowledge yeah it's not enough to that's
not as good as a post mate is in my
opinion yes true yeah but you don't like
to walk around and be surprised at new
products consumers mate man like when
you go to trial I'm just gonna talk
about these you grab some tissue paper
real quick you walk around and then at
the end of the owl is the [ __ ] Excel
and clearance it and you'd be like oh
man totally been needing these polkadot
socks with the balls on the back this is
in only $9.99 I gotta grab them like you
end up spending $100 on a $15.00 trip
dude I didn't even know those are
clearance I'm not gonna be surprised
it's literally at the end of a flight if
this is the ow
like the clearance stuff to be right
here like all of it and you need to
tells you like if it's like Marc dead
the point 89 is gonna go down again if
it's like you think the rich stay rich
by paying full price per pound [ __ ] per
pound price per ounce that's all I got a
look at how much on the corner if it's
15 cent yep what are you paying per
ounce
I was just a cosplay today speaking of
people who [ __ ] walk around who have
no idea what they're gonna buy this lady
picks up a veggie tray at a Costco and
she was examining it like it was a
[ __ ] Rubik's Cube like she had never
seen a penny tree before and then she's
look at the nutritional details and I'm
like it's vegetables with ranch dip
there's nothing else to understand but
she make me sick no no no that people
make you sick when we were at the flea
market and you were just like [ __ ]
going nuts oh I actually realized that
go to a flea market
hell yeah yeah I realize that I have a
lot of pet peeves yeah and one of them
is I [ __ ] hate it when people can't
make up their mind like I don't know
what has nothing to do with me but it
pisses me the [ __ ] off so I'm just
standing there chillin and I see it I
see a lady go like this and I'm like
live life with the [ __ ] purpose know
where the [ __ ] you want to go goal did
it go a hundred miles an hour stop
[ __ ] logs like that's some trainer
[ __ ] pick up the weight no this is my
way back he's a clown though getting all
this anxiety from being up outside and
I'm like why can't people walk in
straight lines like people are walking
in there like looking at this gym I want
to [ __ ] you browsing [ __ ]
stop bro there's like
old lady garden should I buy this and
probably works like [ __ ] get it
already deadly markets are made for
browsing I know there's no listing of
what they have you have to walk around
[Laughter]
but you know like this BAM I go like
this go to the right shirt by I don't go
you don't do that you don't do that ever
have to pick up something to gauge if
it's worth the money I'd like to touch
it yeah anything I touch all the
vegetables I know me too
the tray push it a little bit I don't
even know what I'm looking for
you want to know what's funny it looks
like a bell pepper to be this is the
[ __ ] cherry on top look he just sets
all this [ __ ] right and then this
[ __ ] so people are walking down
this way up this Vicki you can please
give me your chair yeah this
[ __ ] does this [ __ ] to me that
pisses me the [ __ ] off get out of your
chair yes is Cartwright and instead of
staying in his Lane can you move back he
puts it in the [ __ ] middle so that he
can go by it so now he's blocking all
the [ __ ] trash [ __ ] hate you hated
monopolize the hole man well that's
because I have an invisible road in my
eyes so the middle is a double yellow
line which supposed to stall and lock
you know and people are supposed to walk
this side of the road you don't walk in
the middle for Costco membership yes
stay out of my [ __ ] Costco it's even
worse because you got a [ __ ] [ __ ]
Hummer cart yeah this whole table it's
the whole thing I love those funds
though the fact that they go every
direction I love that's it I've drift
with it I mean is it is it meant for a
family of ten gotta be icy look an asset
I see [ __ ] you see six kids on each side
all holding the car I feel I got my
family as a big enough to shop at Costco
I got the car at literally for the
discount on the gas and a discount on
travel if you guys all use Costco
travels it is amazing Costco travels
Cosco travel is like would I book all my
rental cars through like the [ __ ] is
like literally like thirty to forty
percent all that's listen I'm with you
that I don't think I have a right to to
shop there yet probably because my
family's too small just me and Nikki but
cuz like the other day I bought so much
bacon that I don't know I'm gonna do ya
know the baby like this beer dude no but
you just think it's like one thing and
then I open love it I'm like oh my god
there's some good fun so now I'm like
and our fridge is already not the
biggest fridge so the Nikki's like what
da [ __ ] is all this bacon on my
[Applause]
you can't either by kings and small
things like if you try to buy water
it's one gallon water connect it by
plastic handcuffs the three other ones
get all four you can't even separate
them
I hate sales that I'm such a [ __ ]
consumer like whatever like hi six boxes
of Cheerios the same two dollars I'm
like that's the deal but I'm like I
don't even like Cheerios but I ain't
missing a good deal I saw chicken pot
pies it was like [ __ ] 75 of them for
like 5 bucks and I was like it's such a
good deal but I don't even eat these
what do I do
buy oh yeah did you buy them I didn't
mind but you end up spending more you do
but you got it at a premium
you got add a premium but bulk wise
you're spending like a thousand dollars
this is what you do you buy um you give
it to homeless people yeah I have it
here here at the frozen chicken potpie
it gets pretty hot nerd if you end up
spending more cuz you're not even using
what you bought but you feel good about
it
I guess maybe if I could a cadet post
might deliver to almost people cuz ass
but it just takes a lot of time
[Music]
[Music]